AI for IBM Z updates to the IBM Maximo
application suite and the introduction
of IBM ns1 connect all on this episode
of IBM Tech now what's up y'all my name
is Ian and I am back to bring you the
latest and greatest news and
announcements about IBM technology to
kick news off this episode we are
excited to unveil a new suite of AI
offerings for IBM Z and improvements to
the latest IBM zos operating system our
Rich AI offerings are designed to help
clients integrate AI workloads into
their most Mission critical business
applications running on IBM Z to name a
few the AI toolkit for IBM Z and Linux 1
supports popular industry standard op
Source Frameworks so that businesses can
start implementing trustworthy Ai and
the python AI toolkit for IBM zos is a
library of open- source python software
to support Ai and machine learning
workloads we've also enhanced machine
learning for IBM zos this is IBM's
Flagship full life cycle platform
designed to help organizations build
deploy manage and operationalize machine
learning and deep learning models on zos
and finally we've got the AI infused IBM
zos 3.1 which represents a new era in
operating system
intelligence now this is only scratching
the surface of the AI offerings for IBM
Z so make sure you check out the blog
Linked In the description of this video
for a full
rundown next up the release of IBM
Maximo application Suite version 8.11
offers an asset life cycle management
platform that effectively combines eam
APM and RCM in a single platform with
shared data in Industry workflows you
can now reduce time to RCM value through
the recently announced IBM Maximo
reliability strategies their RCM
programs can leverage a database of of
equipment types failure mechanisms and
maintenance tasks we're also bringing
IBM Maximo it to the application Suite
to provide the itsm and itam needed to
simplify the support of users and
infrastructures finally to align the
maximal platform to your industries and
strategies we've launched a new catalog
of solutions that is built within the
maximal application Suite as an online
Marketplace it allows easy access to IBM
and partner technologies that augment
and accelerate the value of Maximo for
specific use cases there are many other
additions to the feature set of Maximo
application Suite in the 8.11 release so
hit the link below to learn
more to wrap things up today let's talk
about a new premium DNS offering from
IBM DNS continues to serve an important
role in how we transact through
applications and data to deliver a fast
and reliable user experience today's
Advanced DNS Services make Dynamic
decisions about about where to send an
internet requests based on availability
performance time of day and many other
calculations we're excited to announced
IBM ns1 connect which showcases how
premium DNS can be a lever of innovation
in today's networks IBM ns1 connect will
Leverage The Power of DNS to deliver
fast reliable connectivity for
applications and websites across the
globe that means a customer experience
that can drive Revenue lower customer
churn and improve the agility of network
teams
a baseline set of features includes a
Global Network a 100% uptime SLA
protection against dos attacks and
support for DNS security extensions you
can also easily route DNS traffic across
our 26 points of presence to help keep
users connected to learn more about IBM
ns1 connect hit the link below thanks so
much for joining me today for this
episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please pleas don't
forget to subscribe to our channel to
stay up toate on what's going on in Tech
now